who's the better artist Drake or Kanye
man I can't even here's what I'll say I
was in the studio one time with Kanye
already I'm like this is the best day of
my life I have my best bullet of content
that I've ever had before it comes out
to like show did he watch yeah and he
was like that's amazing and then Drake
walked in and I had no idea Drake was
even coming and I'm in there with both
of them and I took the opportunity to be
like fellas you guys are by far my
favorite two artists of all time that
whoever is third what a sizable Gap
there is I love Kanye's music not only
just the messaging behind like the
ambition but also the musicality and
Drake came along right when I became
like a rapper nothing has inspired me
more as an actual rapper and musical
artist than Drake every time I feel like
I'm hitting a LOL as a rapper Drake
drops like the most inspiring [__] I've
ever heard and both of them have been so
nice to me so I can't really delineate
between Drake and Kane they're just my
favorite artists ever